[Music]
there's not much of a debate that tom
brady is the greatest quarterback of all
time i think the only question left is
whether he's the greatest player of all
time at any position jerry rice has some
real competition from tom brady but
chris sims the question moving forward
for
brady and more specifically for anyone
else who either is in the pipeline now
or who will be in the future what will
it take to be better than tom brady is
there any way that someone can actually
outdo
tom brady to become the greatest
quarterback of all time given the
standard he set with six super bowl wins
four super bowl mvps three nfl mvps
comeback player of the year 2000's all
decade team he'll surely be on the 100th
anniversary team but i think those six
super bowl wins that's what sets him
apart from the likes of a joe montana a
john elway i mean it for a while it was
montana's the best ever then once brady
got the number five we had to accept the
fact that brady's better now with six
four super bowls in five years they've
been to it's incredible what they've
done at this late stage of his career i
i don't
i don't think anyone's going to have the
time or the opportunity to outdo tom
brady no it's going to be tough i mean
it really is you know i mean you know
it's going to be a special set of
circumstances just like we see with tom
brady and bill belichick i mean it's
going to first thing that is going to
have to happen is they're going to have
to have a special coaching staff and an
organization that's gonna be able to
build a team around a quarterback for
that long of a period of time for him to
succeed so i think that's rare i mean as
rare as tom brady's talents are and how
awesome he is it's even more rare to
have a coach like bill belichick and
everything like that so you got to have
that aspect of it but i know mike like
what will it take i mean you know i i
just don't envision anybody in any time
soon winning six super bowls or more
than that okay and you know i don't know
like if patrick mahomes let's just throw
somebody out there right if he won two
super bowls
and won like five mvps or six mvps or
something like that does he get thrown
into it see that's where i get into the
rings discussion and that bothers me you
know me mike at times because you know
it's a team sport and you know patrick
wilhelm's not gonna be able to play for
bill belichick and do that you know and
and other great quarterbacks didn't get
to do that so i don't know if anybody's
gonna but it's it's got it but it's
gotta be wins right because we just
talked about drew brees and he's gonna
retire with the best numbers in all of
the major categories in the history of
the sport but that's not good enough to
make him even in the top five it's the
championships that set the guy apart and
it's got to be at least six
to get yourself equal to tom brady and
it may have to be seven because they may
get number seven this year uh well you
know
he's gonna be if we're just gonna go on
that and that alone then he's gonna be
the best quarterback in the history of
football for at least the next hundred
years like i really feel that confident
nobody in football ever is gonna be able
to do
what bill belichick and tom brady have
done he's the king that way that's why i
kind of brought up that patrick mahomes
you know thing because i just hey as
awesome as he is and i love andy reid
and all of those things
it's great i just they're not going to
win six super bowls i mean if they do i
don't know what i'll get down and i'll
kiss your feet on the on a show one time
at that time no thank you um yeah no
thank you to me either but they i was
just trying to throw it at examples if
you get close and win more mvps you know
if brady ends up with six super bowls
and he had a maybe a quarterback who won
four super bowls and and and six nfl mvp
awards does that make you put them in
the class what does it take
what does it take for you if you don't
get the rings to mace basically say oh
it's really close right that to me would
be what will it take to get that
conversation started if you don't have
the rings
well and and you know here's the other
side of it too that gets overlooked you
have to be a great quarterback who lands
in the right spot yes with a bill
belichick right you know
when will there be another bill
belichick it's not just when will there
be another tom brady you need another
belichick and another brady to find each
other whether it's through pick number
199 or pick number one or somewhere in
between that's what i'm saying
that's what you're going to need and uh
you know maybe maybe steve belichick
bill's son becomes the next bill
belichick at some point down the road
laying the foundation for a great
quarterback to land with steve belichick
when he's the coach of the patriots in
15 years or whenever it would be and off
they go in that direction but it's just
not going to be easy what we're seeing
now especially in an age of salary cap
and parody and everyone should have a
chance in theory they do every given
year the patriots have cracked every
code possible they are inside of the
safe and they aren't coming out anytime
soon and i think once they're out of it
it's going to be even harder to get
inside of that safe because it's going
to be
virtually impossible to match what the
patriots have done
what we've seen and you know people get
sick of it it gets old
we see what's happened like in
basketball and in hockey you have a team
that wins it all for the first time ever
and it creates a new sense of excitement
and i think it's good when the nfl can
do that
this is a level of greatness that we've
never seen before and i don't think
we're ever going to see again and i
think you just kind of sit back accept
it and and wait for it to end and who
knows when it will yeah but i'm like i'm
with you there that's kind of what i'm
at right now you know there was like a
period there where i was like oh gosh
i'm sick of the patriots but i feel like
the last few years i'm almost like
man this is amazing i love it i'm kind
of rooting for them i i almost sit here
and go man 31 teams in nfl should be
embarrassed with how they just let the
patriots dominate them year after year
after year that's where i look at it at
some point i mean it's just it's
absolute demolishing by the coaching
staff by brady and the offense you know
the defense that's not great but yet
never lets teams score points and things
like that they're just i don't think
we've ever seen anything like this the
only thing in sports in america that i
think even compares would be like the
celtics of the 60s or maybe some of
those yankee runs with babe ruth or joe
dimaggio but it's that special he is
amazing
yeah and uh it's going to be a long long
time i don't think i'm going to be
around maybe you won't be around either
by the time there's somebody better than
tom brady right
we're all ascot next on nbcsn we
continue on radio we'll be right back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports